and now from the i-team a condo complex
is leaking sewage and tenants are just
fed up both the county and the health
district working with the homeowners
association to remedy the problems but
some people who live in the buildings on
desert in near paradise say the damage
is just too great the i-team's david
charns there live with more on their
concerns david
yeah brian denise i do want to let you
know that some of what we're about to
show you isn't really the most pleasant
thing to see while you're eating dinner
but take a look this is the building
we're talking about in addition to those
sewage issues inspectors worry that this
part of the building could collapse
it's absolutely disgusting just a block
from the strip in the shadow of some of
las vegas most expensive rooms is the
desert and villas the place just
deteriorating the walls in some places
of the building are bulging outwards
protruding walls cracking sidewalks and
leaking sewage you can smell it when the
i-team visited the property there were
pieces of toilet paper where raw sewage
had come up through the ground carl
osborne first moved here 30 years ago
i'm really sad that it's gone downhill
the way it has the i-team finding this
building report from february an
inspector noting clogged pipes are
allowing gray water that's everything
but from a toilet to flow onto sidewalks
and into driveways the inspector also
finding pool barrier walls buckling and
signs of structure failure omar mazugu
owns a condo here you know it's
extremely dangerous he says his
apartment flooded earlier this year and
now he won't even sleep here i have been
homeless for nine months even though i
own my property
since last winter osborne and mazugu
have sent the i-team photos and videos
of the ongoing issues issues like county
inspectors deeming the building's front
lobby an imminent hazard to public
safety one side of the building seems to
be tilting one way stand out in front of
the building you can kind of see it
the leaking sewage prompting the health
district to also issue the hoa with a
violation notice they also mentioned to
me that they
hate to condemn the place
because it makes everybody homeless that
everybody would have to move out
because of that hearing from the health
district the hoa has to attend a hearing
that is to talk about those sewage
issues i reached out to the
company that runs this building manages
the building for the hoa they say they
are doing everything they can to make
these fixes but that fixing those pipes
would cost the hoa upwards of a million
dollars we're live near desert inn in
paradise tonight i'm david charns live
local now brian and denise david what
happens next essentially and can people
still live there right now
yeah you know i think a big part of this
story is people are living in this
building many of them veterans so there
will be that hearing about the sewage
issues and then the county is saying
that the h.o.a has to fix these problems
in the next couple months they have
issued a second order for that the work
not done when it was supposed to be done
a couple weeks ago so they're working on
this but again
these are some hefty fines
in a pretty pricey part of town brian
denise